dit que maçon
tallinn
avant un concert de foot ça gâche à son
benoît on va goûter les broyer de la
biscuiterie augereau venez avec nous
bonjour bonjour bienvenue à 10,8 euros
entre
le chiffre et des couches gros je dirige
l'entreprise familiale explique ce
nouveau groupe qui est allé à saint
benoît maintenant depuis 1973 et
prochaine on a fêté nos 50 ans alors un
broyer il ya autant de recettes que de
famille après les étapes que sont
toujours à peu près les mêmes on pétrit
d'abord le beurre et le sucre de façon à
faire un crémage qui ont encore par la
farine une fois qu'on a mélangez les
ingrédients aux formes le gâteau au met
un petit coup de fourchette pour faire
des petits dessins dessus et on passe à
une petite pellicule de jaune d'oeuf
après il reste à le cuir c'est une
chaîne qu'on a fait évoluer au fur et à
mesure comme mon père s'installer en 73
il était dans un petit garage de l'autre
côté de la rocade mais toujours sur
saint benoît qui faisait vingt mètres
carrés et au fur et à mesure on adapte
un outil de production pour pouvoir
faire du bruit il boit tout pour le plus
grand nombre je suis adhérent de la
marque poitou depuis le début nous c'est
ça coulait de source celui que le
poisson c'est la vienne et les deux
sèvres moi mes deux grands pères étaient
plongées faisait aussi du poids et du
poitou 1 dans les deux sèvres et al
viennent donc qui pensent comme le
croyez du poitou où tout est dit dans la
dans le nom tu sais vraiment produits
typiques de cette région dix ans dans sa
gamme c'est le droit du poitou et ses
dérivés donc on retrouve le broyer
standard après on l'a déclinée avec des
petites pépites de chocolat pour essayer
un petit peu de rajeunir un peu la gamme
on a également sorti un boîtier bio
après on a la bonne voisine c'est le
petit deux ans qu'on trouve au milieu
d'un loyer corps d'un petit coup de
fourchette saab en mode et ça faisait un
petit losange à jour du guide et de cuir
et c'est exactement même pas que le
broyer mais la cuisson fait que ça
change leur le produit sauf un petit
produit un peu plus croquant et après on
a la gale et de pau jean vie
dernièrement une sortie des galettes aux
éclats de caramel et après on a aussi
des mini one iq sont une petite étude
plus pour voyager alors les produits
sont principalement distribuée dans la
vienne et deux sèvres dans tous les
magasins aussi bien les la gls les
grandes et moyennes surfaces que aussi
bien les preuves des magasins de
producteurs ou
les vitrines du département même au
futuroscope on est présent ici c'est une
boutique où les gens par ce qui n'est
pas toujours facile d'accès mais les
habitués connaissent le chemin et après
ils viennent aussi pour amener les
commandes pour les mariages comme on a
pu voir l'écran voyez toutes lettres le
plus grands voiliers qu'on a fait il
faisait 13 mètres de haut des points
record